Let's see if we can write
the fraction 11 over 25,
or we could call
11/25, to see if we
can write that as a decimal.
And we're going to round it to
the nearest thousandths place.
And so another way of
viewing this is 11 over 25,
this is the same thing
as 11 divided by 25.
So we can literally divide 25
into 11, and whatever we get,
that is going to be the decimal
representation of 11/25.
And since we're going
to go into the places
less than the ones
place, we're going
to go into the tenths
place, the hundredths place,
and the thousandths place,
let's add some zeroes to this 11
right over here
after the decimal,
and now let's start to divide.
25 doesn't go into 1.
25 doesn't go into 11.
25 does go into 110.
So 25 goes into 110 four times.
4 times 25 is 100.
So it goes into it four times.
Let's keep the decimal up here.
So we'll write 0.4.
4 times 25 is 100.
And now we can subtract
110 minus 100 is 10.
And now we can bring
down another 0.
25 goes into 100
exactly four times.
4 times 25 is 100, and then
you subtract, and you get 0.
So we actually didn't even
have to round this one.
This fraction is exactly 0.44.